When you, uh, set out to do trigger
warning, what did, what was the,
what was the initial premise and how
much of it did it change until when you
need,
once you got to production and once you
started filming one of the only people
who have asked that question, you
can look, this isn't a sparrow. Yeah.
Straight up bro.
Yeah.
Originally we shot it with FX and we over
we over did it. It looked really good,
but it looked really TV. Uh, and
um, it could have been dealt,
but it would have been a parity of a
very real thing I was tempted to do.
And right now I'm talking to my
crib. Nicola, what it turned out at,
turned into at Netflix was a real
mmm.
In your face.
Simple and plainly shot
documentation of the possibilities
of barbershop arguments.
Right? So in a barbershop
argument, you get to say, you know,
the only thing that separates alcohol
from Joe Kennedy is Al Capone got caught
and eventually died in prison. And Joe
Kennedy went on to produce presidents,
but they both had been bootlegged,
you know,
people say Shit like it's
barbershop talk and you need,
you have to go home and be like
yourself. Like, well, well damn,
if Papa Joe did it was a bootlegger.
Like technically it could have went
fucked up for him and we never would have
had an American dynasty
versus owl catching Sibley's
in shit and it not going so
well.
But him being the preeminent marketing
campaign in face of any Capone like
thing, you want to sell cigars to
a restaurant, right? So it got it.
I got a chance to say, you know, Shit,
what if I could do this for my guys?
And again, giving it a shot
and giving them to try it.
I thought of that shit at 15 years old,
I started trying to figure
out how to do it 10 years ago,
Daniel and I got it done eight, nine
years later. And now you have this. And,
and I say that just to say that I read
Brian Koppelman and the creator of
billions, um, is a brilliant writer to me.
And he's a phrase a friend also,
but Brian has been putting up lately
these just encouraging things,
telling writers to write,
even if your stuff is getting body,
even if you don't think is good to write,
to to push yourself to
push the idea forward.
And I've been taking a lot of inspiration
for that because Daniel Daniel
Minefield and I wanted a co
writer who's in cocreators.
Daniel and I have been talking and
developing this over 10 years now.
I know how to do it, how to go on
a room, how to get it, you know,
it won't take me 10 years for the next
one, but it was worth the struggle,
you know, it was worth doing
that. It was worth tweaking.
My ideal is worth critiquing my idea to
be like the first time around like nine.
It's not,
it's not what it should be because I
was nervous as shit the night before it
came out about everything in it.
You know what scenes were shot,
how did it look to production value and
now seeing people get it and unlike a
lot of other artists, not have to call
yourself a genius. Let me tell people's,
like every artist thinks days it changes.
Every comedian thinks they're fucking
Richard Pryor and some part of your mind,
you have to think you're
great or why do it?
You have believe there's greatness in you.
Right?
But I'd never want it to be the guy. I'm
a fucking genius. You know what I mean?
I just never want it. But
to see it, because I always
thought the idea was genius.
Like fuck that shit.
You remember real people that used to
come on in the seventies eighties I
remember watching that show as a kid
looking at motherfuckers like, wow,
these motherfuckers exist in it and he's
off far off places like Iowa and Kansas
and I wanted to approach it.
I wanted to approach people in a very,
I'm here right in front of you, kind
of way. Not Above you, not celebrity,
Michael Morris.
The people know I'm a rapper and it gave
me that opportunity and people can say
as genius and I'm going to say I'm humbled
and honored but you're fucking right
and it's genius because I'm engaging
people at a regular human level,
not at the level of celebrity or power.
There used to be an engaged but one
that allows them to fully open up.
I haven't seen it on TV since.
Some shit like real people or no,
I haven't seen revolutionary TV like
the Jeffersons or you know all in the
family or mod and I think that the world
is getting scary and pussy to be honest.
You know,
not to,
not to disrespect pussies cause pussies
are tough but I think that something
needs to be dangerous.
The best compliment I got on this press
run has been like Ambrosia Ambrosia for
head said.
How's it feel to have some most dangerous
show on TV and it's dangerous because
it unites people.
Does it separate people?
It gives you alternative answers
and the ones you thought you had,
it forces you to think it doesn't solve
all the problems or wrap it up pretty at
the end. Gives you some options to
do and some shit to think about.
And it's funny as fuck. And so first
if in dark and I like it. I was,
I got an imagine Netflix give
you plenty of room. Yeah.
Hell they weren't tripping man. They
don't trip. Don't trip. Just go.
You know what you're doing.
Go ahead. Yeah, exactly.
And then you walk in the room
like how the fuck I'm doing.
But there is smart enough to let people
create their own shit for standup
comedy.
There's no one better in terms of like
interacting with them about a special,
you don't have to give them any
notes on the material. They,
they know that you're going to do your
best. I stope yeah, they don't stop.
They can't help you.
Like no one can help you as a comic.
There's a another person,
like an executive is going
to help you do your best.
You gotta you gotta be looking at it
yourself ruthlessly and you'll figure it
out. And so they trust you. So I would
assume they did the same thing with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Perfect.
Beautiful. All right. What a
world. Yeah, the forever the,
it was the opposite.
There was 50 fucking cooks in the kitchen
and everybody's pulling you this way
and you need to do what to do. It's just
shit. You need a fucking theme song.
You got, you need a thing. You say
every week, which you talk about Willis,
you need to hook. Everybody
needed a hook. Oh Shit. She said,
oh my God.
Shouts it different strokes.